another day another instance of Donald
Trump's swamp filling cronyism Donald
Trump has selected Kelley night craft as
the next US ambassador to the United
Nations replacing nikki Haley who bailed
out on Trump last year the US Senate has
confirmed her and it just so happens
that she was a VIP guest of Donald
Trump's Trump International Hotel what a
surprise right
she used to be ambassador to Canada
while she was listen to this she made 29
visits to Donald Trump's hotel she was
outside of Canada 58% of the time that
she was ambassador to Canada and she
stayed at Donald Trump's hotels so often
that she achieved what's called Gold
level membership status in the trump
card rewards program she really got
beyond Gold level rewards she got
herself an ambassadorship from staying
at Donald Trump's hotel so often can you
even imagine the trump card rewards is
the sort of it's a Pyrrhic victory even
if you win the trump card rewards game
you've really lost in some kind of
broader existential sense and we heard
from Democratic Senator Bob Menendez who
just straight-up called this out for
what it is he said two senators don't
vote to confirm her uh rampant
absenteeism conflicts of interest and
the Republicans just don't care we were
told during the campaign that Donald
Trump would end the swamp he would stop
the revolving door of cronies coming in
and out he would appoint people who have
qualifications rather than his friends
and it's all a lie I mean I guess okay
he's not just appointing his friends
he's also appointing really good
customers of his in the hotel business
so in that sense I guess he is not just
or merely appointing friends I have a
question for the trumpet's who watch the
David Pakman show or listen to the show
can you defend this nomination seriously
okay if you think this is good if you
think this is anything other than
cronyism get in touch via email or send
me a tweet at D Pakman how do you defend
it and here's let me give you a hint if
your defense of this nomination is meant
going to mention Hillary Clinton or
Barack Obama it's not a good one if your
defense of this nomination is going to
mention the
Hilary Clinton Foundation I'm sorry the
Clinton Foundation or Hillary Clinton's
emails it's not a good defense okay what
I want to hear from you is tell me
exactly how this is a qualified person
who should be ambassador and how this is
anything other than the exact just exact
type of cronyism that Donald Trump told
us he was going to be rooting out I
don't see any way and what it
fundamentally comes down to in the end
is that this is just politics as usual
despite what we were told was going to
be different and this is why you know
whenever you have a candidate who comes
in and says based on my different
background I will be completely
different
as a politician this is what a lot of
people don't understand the reason that
we end up with the status quo
politicians once they are politicians is
the system forces them into that this is
not a defensive Donald Trump Donald
Trump was particularly corrupt and crony
istic but let's say we believe imagine
for a second that Donald Trump came from
the business world but not the corrupt
crony capitalist business world look
let's just say he was a respectable
business person and he says I'm not
going to do the revolving door of
lobbyists elected official corporate
stuff I'm not gonna do that I'm not
gonna hand out ambassadorships to people
who are customers of mine he might have
really said that honestly in Trump's
case it wasn't true but then the system
allows for and encourages for people to
do that so a lot of times it's sort of
like a chicken egg thing do we have the
corrupt crony capitalist system that we
have because the people who we elect
already have those predispositions or
does the system mold and craft those
people into becoming that regardless of
what they were when they got elected
it's probably a combination of both but
the challenge stands if you think this
is a reasonable nomination on the merits
then I want to hear from you at Dee
Pakman on Twitter the show is also on
twitter at david pakman show follow me
follow the show follow everybody we'll
take a quick break and be back right
after this